I think people should be a little more
respectful of our fellow citizens and
when you guys have people up here she
you should always ask the why not like
it's a binary thing you're supporting
Trump you're not supporting Trump JP
Morgan CEO Jamie Diamond was there and
Diamond I thought quite well explained
why Trump is back and why people uh
support the guy I wish the Democrats
would think a little more carefully when
they talk about Maga when people say
Maga they're actually looking at people
voting for Trump and they think they're
voting and they're basically
scapegoating them that you are like him
uh and but I don't think they're voting
for Trump because of his family values
if you look just take a step back be
honest he was kind of right about NATO
kind of right about immigration he grew
the economy quite well tra China virus
tax reform worked he was right about
some of China I don't I don't like what
he did no I said China virus he may have
right and I don't like how he said
things about Mexico I don't like but he
wasn't wrong about some these critical
issues and that's why they're voting for
him and and I think people should be a
little more respectful of our fellow
citizens and when you guys have people
up here you should always ask the why
not like it's a binary thing you're
supporting Trump you're not supporting
Trump why are you supp hard to hate 75
million of your fellow Americans and
it's I agree done you know the Democrats
have done a pretty good job with the
deplorables hugging on their Bibles and
their beer and their guns I mean really
like could we just stop that stuff and
actually grow up and treat other people
with respect and listen to him a little
bit and and I do think the economy will
affect I think this this negative talk
about Maga is going to hurt Biden's
election campaign yeah that's just right
that's just right because what's Jamie
Diamond doing there he's defending just
the average American just a mom who
wants to know what her kid is learning
right just a person who works at a
company and doesn't want to be
discriminated against because they
happen to be straight and white but all
of these people have pushed so far that
they have actually uh summoned Donald
Trump from the gates of hell once
again